this is why i like
like folks in the artificial
intelligence space elon musk and uh
a few others speak about this and they
look at the long arc they say like
what you know this kind of you know you
can call it like first principles
thinking or you can call anything
really is like if we just zoom off from
our
current bickering and our current like
discussions in the what science is doing
and
look at the long arc of the trajectory
we're headed at
which questions are obviously
fundamental
to science and that should be asked and
which is the space of hypotheses we
should be exploring
and like exoplanets is a really good
example of one that was like
an obvious one i recently talked to
sarah seeger
and it was very taboo when she was
starting out to work on an exoplanet and
that was even in the 90s
yeah and uh like it's obvious
should not be a taboo subject and to me
i mean i'm probably ignorant but
to me exoplanets seems like it's
ridiculous that that would ever be a
taboo subject right to not fund to not
explore
that's very but even for her it's now
taboo to
say like what
you know to to look for industrial
pollution right right
it's like i find that ridiculous i'll
tell you why you take the next step it's
ridiculous
for another reason yes not because of
just the scientific benefits that we
might have by exploring it
but because the public cares about these
questions
yes and the public funds science
so how dare the scientists shy away from
addressing these questions
if they have the technology to do it
it's like saying i don't want to look
through galileo's telescope it's exactly
the same you have the technology to
explore this question
to find evidence and you shy away from
it
you might ask why do people shy away
from it yes
and perhaps it's because of the fact
that there is science fiction i i'm not
a fan of science fiction because it has
an element to it that violates the laws
of physics in many of the books and
and the films and i cannot enjoy the
these things when i see the laws of
physics violated but
who cares that the you know the fact
that there is science fiction i mean if
if you have the scientific methodology
to address the same subject
i don't care that other people you know
spoke nonsense about this subject
or said things that make no sense who
cares you do your scientific work
just like you explore the dark matter
you explore the possibility that umuamua
is an artifact you just look for
evidence
and try to deduce uh what what it means
and i have no problem with doing that to
me it sounds like any other scientific
question that we have
and given the public's interest we have
an obligation to do that
by the way science to me is not an
occupation of the elite
it doesn't allow me to feel superior to
other humans that are unable to
understand the math
to me it's a it's a way of life you know
if there is a problem in the faucet or
in the pipe
at home i try to figure out what the
problem is and
with a plumber we figure it out and you
know we look at the clues and
the same thing in science you know you
look at the evidence you try to figure
out what it means
it's it's common sense in a way and
it shouldn't be regarded as something
removed from the public
it should be a reflection of the
public's interest and
i think it's actually a crime to resist
the public
if the public says i care about this and
you say no no that's not sophisticated
enough for me
i want to do intellectual gymnastics on
anti the sitter space
to me that's a crime yes i'd uh 100
agree
you